H
FOR YOUR EXPERTISE.
>> THANK YOU, APPRECIATE IT,
JESSE.
>> Jesse: LAURA LOGAN, MASS
CONFUSION, SOURCES ON THE GROUND
AND FAMILIES THE DESPERATE TO
GET OUT OF THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
>> WELL, JESSE, I WAS ON THE
PHONE PRETTY MUCH ALL THROUGH
THE NIGHT LAST NIGHT WITH MANY
FAMILIES ON THE GROUND AND THE
NUMBER OF THEM WORKED WITH ME ON
"60 MINUTES" FOR 20 YEARS AND
THAT'S WHY I'M HELPING THEM GET
OUT.
THEY HAVE BEEN THREATENED AND
THEY ARE TARGETS.
IT WAS REALLY THE MOST -- IT WAS
ONE OF THE MOST DISTRESSING
THINGS I'VE EVER EXPERIENCED
BECAUSE WHEN THE BOMBS WENT OFF,
THEY WERE TELLING ME THAT KIDS
ARE SCREAMING.
OF MOST THAT YOU HAVE SEEN
ACROSS THE MEDIA TODAY OF ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE LYING DEAD
AND WOUNDED TO, THOSE WERE TAKEN
BY THE BROTHER OF OUR 60 MINUTES
AFGHAN PRODUCER.
FOR JOE BIDEN TO STAND UP THERE
ON THE DAY THAT ALL THESE
AFGHANS ARE BEING KILLED AND TO
PRETEND THAT THIS IS SOME KIND
OF TRAGEDY AND HE CARES ABOUT
THE DEATH OF AMERICAN SOLDIERS,
IF HE CARED ABOUT IT, WHY DID
YOU DO IT?
WHY DID YOU CREATE THE
SITUATION?
WHY ARE YOU DOING ANYTHING TO
CHANGE OR?
GOING TO THE TALIBAN AND ASKING
CAN WE STOP PRETENDING NOW THAT
THE TALIBAN ARE NOT TERRORISTS?
CAN WE STOP PRETENDING THAT THE
NETWORK IS NOT THE NUMBER TWO,
THE LEADER OF THE HOT COUNTY
NETWORK
, THE DEPUTY COMMANDER OF
THE TALIBAN.
LET'S PRETEND THEY ARE NOT ISIS.
OLD FRIEND OF MINE, I
INTERVIEWED HIM MANY TIMES, WHEN
WE INTERROGATE THE PEOPLE, GET
THEM ON THE BATTLEFIELD YOU KNOW
WHAT WE FIND OUT?
TODAY THEY ARE ISIS, TWO WEEKS
AGO THEY WERE TALIBAN, TO TELL
MIKE TO A YEAR'S AGO THERE
WERE AL QAEDA.
THE AMERICANS --
>> Jesse: THEIR FOOLING
JOE BIDEN ENDED SO SLIPPERY
GROUP OF
TRIBESMEN.
THEY CHANGE SIDES CONSTANTLY.
THEY'RE ALL CORRUPT.
THE FACT JOE DID NOT SEE THE
ARMY COLLAPSING LIKE THIS, WHO
IS HE KIDDING?
I'VE NEVER BEEN OVER THERE AND
YOU GO ONLINE AND LOOK AT IT AND
HAVE YOU SEEN THE JUMPING JACKS?
THESE GUYS COULD NOT TELL TIME.
THERE WERE SMOKING, AND THEY
COULD NOT HOLD THE ADVANCE?
NO WONDER THEY WENT BACK TO THE
FIELD.
>> I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU A COUPLE
OF THINGS.
IT DID NOT COLLAPSE IN 11 DAYS.
ALSO DO NOT FORGET TO THE
COMMANDOS SPECIAL FORCES THAT'S
IN THE BACK BONE AND THEY ARE
BORNE THE BRUNT OF MOST OF THE
OPERATIONS.
THESE GUYS ARE AMONG THE BEST
WITH ANY MILITARY IN THE WORLD.
IF YOU DO NOT SEE MUCH OF THEM
BUT THEY ARE INDISTINGUISHABLE
FROM AMERICANS WHEN YOU DO SEE
THEM ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
OF THEY'VE DONE THOUSANDS OF
OPERATIONS.
THEIR SPECIALIZED FORCES THAT
RELY ON MOBILITY.
WHEN YOU TAKE AWAY THE AIR FORCE
AND THE AIR SUPPORT, WHAT DO YOU
DO?
YOU CAN HAVE A GROUP OF DELTA
OPERATORS AND IF THERE OUT
NUMBERED, SURROUNDED, THE SAME
THING'S GOING TO HAVE BEEN TO
MANY OF THESE GUYS.
THEY WERE EXECUTED WHEN THEY
SURRENDERED.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THOUSANDS OF
MORE OF THEM, THEY FOUGHT THEIR
WAY FROM THE SOUTH AND ACROSS
THE MOUNTAINS TO THE VALLEY
WHERE THEY WENT WITH THEIR
EQUIPMENT.
THEY ARE FIGHTING NOW TODAY.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS NOT, HE'S
LYING.
HE'S TAKEN THE BLOOD OF OUR
AFGHAN -- YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND NOW?
AMERICANS, THESE GOOD AMERICANS
WHO SERVED ALONGSIDE THESE
PEOPLE HAVE SAID WE WILL NOT BE
PART OF THE BETRAYAL THAT IS
DRENCHED IN THE BLOOD OF AFGHAN
AND THE BLOOD OF U.S. MARINES AS
WELL.
THIS GOVERNMENT IS LYING ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
I KNOW PEOPLE IN THE EVACUATION
TODAY WHO SAID THERE IS NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO THE 7,000 NUMBERS THAT
WENT OUT IS ABSOLUTELY FALSE
THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE THE
EQUIPMENT IN PLACE.
NOT THAT MANY PEOPLE ALLOWED IN.
WE KNOW ALL OF US UP ALL NIGHT,
THAT'S WHY MY VOICE IS CRAZY.
WE KNOW THEY'VE BEEN TURNING
AWAY PEOPLE AND AMERICAN
CHILDREN BORN IN THE COUNTRY.
IF PARENTS NOT BEING ALLOWED TO
GET ON PLANES.
>> Jesse: THEY CAN'T HIDE IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN AS THE
PLANES ARE TAKING OUT, THERE IS
FIVE GUYS IN THERE.
PLANES EMPTY.
I DO KNOW WHAT TO HEAR ANYMORE
NUMBERS ABOUT THE SUCCESS.
IT'S A SCRAMBLE TO THE GATES
BECAUSE HE BOOTED IT.
IF BRADLEY CAN SEE IT
, GROUND SUPPORT ANYBODY KNOWS
IT.
I'VE GOT TO RUN, THANK YOU S